it's not just a new year it's also a
whole new currency and here in Croatia
feelings are mixed every country who
took on the Euro their standards of
Living went down I think is going to be
the same in Croatia I'm not happy
because I think everything will be more
expensive to be honest I don't really
care about it that much so I think it
it's probably a natural transition
and that's fine with me when it comes to
business Imports exports and the tourism
that Croatia is hugely reliant on many
say it's a benefit more than half of our
external trade is done with Eurozone
countries and approximately
two-thirds of the tourist overnight
stays are done by the theories who are
coming from the Euro area so for us it's
a huge it's important for our tourism
for our economy Jeweler Mario nokai
agrees I think it will be easier to to
work
and many levels and we don't lose money
on conversions the challenge in the
short term however is that for the next
two weeks the local kuna currency can
still be used to buy but the change must
be in Euros we will be a little exchange
but I will push more card payment and
just to to
slowly transition you know but I think I
hope the card payment will work good so
if that breaks out then we are in cows
the first day of 2023 has another first
two as the euro currency takes over here
Croatia is also entering the Schengen
Zone it's the first time a country
adopts both on the same day and that
means that from now on if you're
entering or exiting from the Schengen
zone no more Identity or border tracks
most of Croatia's foreign visitors are
European so it means a lot definitely no
borders and the
Border controls and the free movement of
people and everything yeah for now it's
the new Euro that is one of the main
subjects of conversation prices will
continue to be displayed in both
currencies as the people navigate their
way through the transition
I'm sorry we are losing the kuna but
nobody asked the people I feel sorry
because I think a country which has its
own currency maintains its identity and
historical values not just an economic
and political change but for many here
the loss of a small sense of Croatian
identity even if it comes with benefits
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera Zagreb